good evening and welcome to tucker
carl's tonight we want to begin by
noting something obvious because this is
the obvious show
if you live in the united states you may
have noticed that many of our public
spaces have become permanent homeless
encampments you see trash filled tents
blotting out what were once green and
tidy public parks you step over vagrants
drooling unconscious on the steps of
train stations on the way to work you
watch as junkies smoke meth without any
embarrassment at all and then yell at
pedestrians on the sidewalk maybe at
your children everywhere at every
intersection there are beggars
it's what we used to imagine india was
like but this is not calcutta this is
new york and san francisco and austin
texas
so the question is what happened and the
short answer is our leaders did this
no matter what they tell you
homelessness is not an act of god it's
not the result of economic collapse in
this country america did not run out of
housing
instead a determined group of
well-funded ideologues decided to make
it easier to live on the streets in this
country while doing drugs therefore many
more people now live on the streets
while doing drugs
see
not complicated
in 2005 an unemployed alcoholic called
basil humphrey enrolled in a rehab
program in boise idaho when humphrey
refused to stop drinking the rescue
mission kicked him out those were the
rules and he spent months sleeping
outside as so many do
eventually local authorities ticketed
him for camping on public property that
was the law
the story would have ended there except
that a huge corporate law firm in new
york city called latham and watkins took
an interest in the case on the other
side of the country now typically latham
and watkins represents wall street banks
and prominent democratic office holders
but the firm wanted to change vagrancy
laws to increase homelessness why did
they want that we don't know but the
firm filed a lawsuit on bazel humphreys
behalf against the city of boise that
suit made it to the ninth circuit court
of appeals in 2018 the court declared
that cities have no right to criminalize
homelessness in fact the court ruled
cities have an obligation to provide
free housing to the homeless at public
expense
the supreme court later upheld that
ruling the case was known as martin vs
boise and it had exactly the effect that
latham and watkins intended
city officials across the country no
longer had an obligation to protect the
public and public spaces from drug
addicts who decided to live in them
at the same time politicians suddenly
had access to a massive new source of
cash
taxpayer money many billions in taxpayer
money for something called homelessness
prevention
now what does homelessness prevention
well of course it's the opposite of what
they call it as always
here's seattle's interpretation of
homelessness prevention
a handful of seattle's more than 12
thousand homeless will soon be going
from the street to a new apartment with
stunning views of the space needle and
puget sound using part of its share of
the 1.9 trillion dollar covet relief
package the city bought three brand new
apartment buildings for 50 million
dollars for 165 homeless a price of
three hundred thousand dollars per unit
in los angeles skid row is about to get
a new neighbor a 19-story high-rise for
homeless costing taxpayers 160 million
dollars or 580 thousand dollars per unit
they're part of an expensive push to get
the homeless off of sidewalks and out of
city parks and into government
subsidized housing even if it means
buying new buildings at market rate from
developers
oh
stunning views of the space deal in
puget sound do you have one of those
well crack heads do
more than half a million dollars per
apartment to
house drug addicts at public expense at
market rates
so you can see why real estate
developers would strongly support a
program like that and of course they
strongly do
but luxury apartments are just the
beginning seattle's most recent
municipal budget allocates more than 150
million dollars to other so-called
homelessness programs just this year
now keep in mind seattle has fewer than
750 000 people living there so that's an
awful lot of money per bum
it's certainly a lot more than anyone
else is getting in seattle
at the same time it was giving
overpriced condos to drug addicts with
stunning views of puget sound
seattle allocated just 10 million
dollars total for its small business
stabilization fund designed to keep
family businesses from going bankrupt
during the covid lockdowns
so the city's priorities could not be
clearer than that you lavish money on
the least productive most anti-social
parasites in our society and then you
punish americans who work for a living
got it
and it's hardly just seattle the latest
city budget in san francisco proposes
spending 667 million dollars on
something called the department of
homelessness and supportive housing
and yet at the very same time san
francisco's department of children youth
and families gets less than half that
amount
a city program designed to help
low-income families pay college tuition
gets just 16 million dollars total
that's about two percent of what the
homeless get
so in san francisco it makes sense in
fact it pays to get high on the sidewalk
don't bother to get education nobody
cares
that's the message from the city
couldn't be clear
in austin texas the city's budget for
homelessness assistance was 68 million
dollars last year at the very same time
the city of austin spent just 3.5
million dollars in new loans for
struggling small businesses and only
seven million dollars for quote mission
critical infrastructure and deferred
maintenance at city facilities like the
things that matter and at the same time
as this was going on the police
department in the city of austin
got an 11 million budget cut
so what happened to the homelessness in
austin the problem they were trying to
quote solve well to no one's surprise it
has grown by 10 percent in just two
years you get what you pay for when you
pay for homelessness you get a lot more
of it see how that works
in los angeles politicians have spent
billions quote fighting homelessness
this has been accompanied of course by a
massive increase in the number of people
who are homeless
four years ago the city spent 440
million dollars in what it called
solutions to homelessness that was
supposed to fix the problem did it huh
homelessness in los angeles jumped 15
just last year
so this year la will spend more close to
a billion dollars on the homeless in
2022.
as for the small businesses crushed by
the city's lunatic covert restrictions
you ask what'll they get well they get
62 million dollars total
the city's gang reduction program gets
about half that
so politicians in los angeles are at the
very least very clear about their
priorities
what is this done to la we don't have to
look far to see the answer to that
last week a homeless man walked into a
furniture store in the west side of los
angeles and murdered a graduate student
who was working alone there he stabbed
her to death for no apparent reason and
then walked out he's still at large she
was 24 now she's dead
today her father told fox and friends
that he holds city officials responsible
for the killing watch
what's endemic in our society right now
is that everybody seems to be oriented
on
giving back rights
and bestowing
favor on people
that
rob others of their rights
we should be celebrating
the good of people and trying to
recognize
that that's
the job they have is to try to elevate
that to make communities better to make
people care more
to
not
tear down communities by exposing them
to
people
that are falling out the bottom that
really don't care
about the other human beings and just
think they can
do whatever they like in our society and
they are doing it more and more
in every community
pretty composed for a man who just lost
his child but he's absolutely right
focusing our attention and our money
on people who contribute nothing who
only detract from the project that is
this country don't help their
communities or anybody's community who
hurt other people who live solely for
themselves who are in danger to the rest
of us that's insane
and so that girl died and she wasn't the
only one
last month in los angeles a man called
carrie bell murdered a 70 year old
emergency room nur she was on her way to
work one of the people we should be
celebrating now she's dead
who's the man who killed her while bell
had a long criminal record he had a
prior arrest in l.a he had arrested
other states as well but authorities let
him go and kept letting him go bell was
homeless he was a victim he was part of
a protected class
then he killed somebody here's fox la's
report on that
days after a brutal attack at a union
station bus stop a beloved nurse lost
her life sandra shells worked at l.a
county usc medical center for decades
where she was highly respected and
revered shells was allegedly assaulted
thursday morning by a homeless man now
identified by police as 48-year-old keri
bell they say he hit shells for no
apparent reason the force knocking her
to the ground and fracturing her skull
police say they found him sleeping
nearby about 90 minutes later and
arrested him without incident
she was an emergency room nurse
walking alone to work
and now she's dead another woman
murdered by the homeless and don't lie
to yourself no one in l.a is ever going
to do anything about it you're probably
going to hear outraged noises for a few
days or i'm from france but politicians
will quickly get back to showering the
unhoused community with another billion
dollars
what you're watching here is
civilization collapsing in real time and
it's not new here's video our producers
shot in los angeles in the spring of
2019 almost three years ago it shows
homeless encampments downtown on three
separate blocks it starts at fifth in
san pedro and then it goes west
seemingly forever
so in january of 2020 the la times
reported that quote california's
railroad tracks are now lined with men
and women sleeping in tents or under
cardboard boxes in america by the way
well in response to this
governor gavin newsom announced another
12 billion dollars in state funding to
quote fight homelessness
how'd that work we'll hear the results
from sky fox the images are startling
thousands of empty or damaged packages
lining the tracks along the union
pacific la railway amazon packages ups
boxes all meant for delivery to
customers along the west coast they're
open by cargo thieves who take advantage
of the trains stopping or slowing down
to break into the containers union
pacific officials saying they've had a
hundred and sixty percent increase in
cargo thefts in the l.a county area with
over 90 containers broken into every day
so i guess they didn't clean up the
railroad tracks
12 billion dollars and disorder got
worse but of course allowing people to
live outside and defecate outside in
public places and use drugs outside in
front of our children
is both the cause and a symptom of
growing disorder and chaos it's the
degradation of what holds us together as
a civilization
so our producers are back in la right
now shooting a documentary for season
two of our tucker carlson original
series on fox nation it's going to be
out soon you're seeing some of the
footage on your screen right now what
you're seeing now was shot this morning
on skid row skid row in la is a 50 block
neighborhood east of downtown and it's
hard to overstate just how dystopian it
is you should go for yourself sometime
and drive through roll them up but watch
you will not believe this is america the
country you grew up in
this is what california got for 12
billion dollars not fewer homeless just
better funded homeless and thousands
more of them
so like covid and oxycontin and
virtually everything else that's
wrecking the country our ancestors built
this
is a manufactured crisis it didn't
happen by accident people paid for it
in new york officials have given drug
addicts priority over virtually everyone
else in the city a lot of working poor
in new york we ought to be celebrating
them the city isn't it's ignoring them
in 2015 the annual budget of the new
york city department of homeless
services was 950 million this year it's
double that it's about two billion
dollars now how much is that
well what they're spending on the
homeless in new york city is more than
the city's entire public university
system more than they get to educate far
more people so the homeless are getting
more per student to live outside and
smoke meth
is that creating fewer homeless probably
not in fact new york's homeless
population is now at its highest level
since the great depression
so where's all this money going
specifically now we could do five hours
on this but here's just one example that
money is going to an overdose prevention
center
preventing overdoses which in fact means
helping the homeless get high
officially called an overdose prevention
center it's a place where users can
snort smoke swallow or inject illegal
drugs in a controlled environment two
centers in east harlem and washington
heights are the first in the nation to
allow supervised drug use the head of an
east harlem community organization says
the facility and a nearby methadone
clinic have led to an unwanted influx of
addicts they all come here from
different areas of the city
we never had this around here
no matter how bad it was through the 60s
all that we never had this around here
it's pretty funny watching people look
confused as they see us what's going on
here i don't remember this but it's not
complicated at all it couldn't be
simpler politicians are making it much
easier to be a homeless drug addict in
the united states and much harder to be
a law-abiding member of the middle class
what's the effect well let's see the
middle class is dying and we now have
record numbers of drug-addicted vagrants
what does that tell you it tells you
that incentives work
if you destroy the nuclear family which
they have if you decriminalize drugs
which they have if you hand out tents
and needles to addicts
what do you think is going to happen
you're going to get more addicts living
in tents again it's not complicated this
is not a vexing public policy question
that requires the brooking institution
to investigate it's not like fixing
social security
and the solution is as simple as the
problem here's the solution stop putting
up with it
say no no you can't smoke meth in the
park you're not allowed to crap on the
sidewalk pull up your pants and get the
hell out of here go somewhere with lower
standards head for a place where
politicians don't care about their
people because we do care and that's why
we're hauling your tent to a landfill
and cutting off your checks today you
are a drug addict get a job or leave
this is our city you are not allowed to
wreck it you didn't build it
know that's not hard
that works we know it works because
that's how societies function for about
2 000 years if you're an unmarried man
with no job you were not allowed to
destroy things
it wasn't your right
by the way this is how successful
families still operate to this day in
the privacy of their own homes when the
ngos aren't watching parents reward good
behavior and they do not tolerate bad
behavior
why because if you let your kids smoke
weed at the breakfast table they will so
you don't let them
so why not apply the same standard to
the drug addicts at penn station because
what we're doing now isn't compassionate
it's an attack on civilization i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis